there was one time on a UFC broadcast we
had two fighters competing Andre Ewell
and Chris Gutierrez the why for both of
those guys is their sons that they
aren't allowed to see mistakenly I wish
I could take it back but I tied their
two stories together this is why these
guys fight they're both heavy-hearted
right not a day of my life goes by where
some UFC fan doesn't reach out to me on
Twitter or Instagram and says something
about the custody why phraseology wasn't
good the term custody battle obviously
Rings true with a lot of people and
there are a lot of negative connotations
because it's a battle between former
spouses in a lot of situations when
Chris Gutierrez wins the fight you know
I felt a little bit Vindicated because
he's crying in the octagon with Joe
Rogan and had I not mentioned it then
why is he crying he's crying because
he's being kept from his son when I got
off the air that night and I saw my
mentions thousands right I've never had
more mentions getting off the air that's
something I'm going to be dealing with
for the rest of my broadcasting career
well I mean bro we're three years ago my
mentions right now like there's a
custody battle mentioned today